Film Courage: Dan how was it for you to get your first
job as a script reader? And if you can
paint a little bit about your life at
that time?
Daniel Calvisi, Screenwriter: Well I'd gotten out of NYU film and I
definitely was interested in
screenwriting that was kind of my focus
coming out of film school and I really
wanted to get into script reading and I
had been interning at the Tribeca Film
Center in New York for a company that
was co-owned by Robert De Niro's
production company and in the same
building was Miramax Films and so I I
just kind of got to know some people
there and it was funny my first reading
job for them it was their genre division
called dimension films and I remember
calling up the supervisor there or no
I'm sorry I remember getting a referral
to them but the guy said they're not
hiring now don't bother calling them and
because I was you know I had a lot of
initiative I called anyway and the first
thing the supervisor told me when he
picked up the phone was oh we have a
reader job open do you want to test for
it and so I did a test coverage which is
they give you a script that they've
already had coverage on and so I did
coverage on it so then they evaluate
they evaluate you on that coverage
because they already know the script
really well and so that's how I got
working for them and then I transferred
over to the Miramax division which was
their parent company and I had I had
also been freelancing for a number of
other companies in New York City other
production companies and studios so when
you came to New York to go to NYU do you
remember like some of the scripts in
your mind that you thought this is the
sort of the genre I want to write in
this is what I want to create well I'd
been it was funny because the growing up
I was really kind of more into I guess
like Spielberg stuff or kind of more
action stuff like Rambo and that kind of
stuff but then before I went to NYU I
transferred in as a junior I started
getting into Scorsese and I was
watching you know taxi driver and that
kind of stuff and Goodfellas and Oliver
Stone and I knew that Scorsese and
Oliver Stone and Spike Lee had gone to
NYU so I really wanted to go there so I
applied and I got in just on the wait
list and then they had called really
late in the summer before my junior year
and said we have an opening on the
waitlist so that's why I went to NYU
that's how I was able to get in and it
was just really cool to be in New York
where these filmmakers that I really
admired had gone you know
so yeah Scorsese Oliver Stone Spike Lee
the Coen brothers and these were all
filmmakers that I really you know wanted
to emulate so going back to what your
jobs were what your tasks were so you
finally get in here you were told
sorry don't even bother you give it a
shot anyway it turns out as luck would
have it they do have a slot do you
remember what your first few weeks were
as the script reader and well I remember
because I got I got scripts and books
because I was in New York and that was
the literary capitals so I would read a
lot of books ahead of publication they
the agents and book editors would send a
book out to the studios to see if any
studios or production companies wanted
option the movie rights and so I would
be the first reader at the production
company or studio to read that
unpublished galley version and that was
hard to do because a lot of times they
would literally give you a 600 page book
to read overnight and I had to write up
a three to five page report about it
by you know noon the next day and that
was hard to do I actually got I got let
go from one of my jobs early on because
I just I just couldn't turn over the
material that fast and so I had to kind
of learn on the job trial by fire and
just learned to read really fast and to
intuit that structure that movie
structure
and as I'm reading this book I'm asking
myself will this transfer over to a
movie you know does it have that
potential for that 3/4 act structure
that 95% of great movies use and so it
was all about structure there wasn't
also dialogue things ya know it was it
was evaluating the whole thing as a
reader I was evaluating the whole script
structured dialogue you know character
development all that stuff but if you're
reading something like a novel or a
graphic novel or even like a piece from
The New Yorker or Rolling Stone or you
know any kind of article that they're
interested in making a movie of you have
to evaluate it as a potential movie so
you're asking yourself does it have the
three or four act structure of a
commercial film so that's interesting so
it sounds actually fairly intimidating
because I know I've been in situations
like that where no one really tells you
what the rules are you kind of have to
as you said into it or watch other
people so how was that where were people
actually giving you tips on how to do
with all that or no you kind of had to
every man for himself
not a whole lot you didn't get a whole
lot of feedback when I was first
starting out maybe a few supervisors
might have given me a few little tips
about coverage but after a while they
don't really give you any feedback you
don't even know where this script goes
after you send in your coverage report
so I would really have to ask afterward
like hey that that script that I really
loved that anything happened with it and
so they might tell me oh we didn't buy
it but Fox bought it or something like
that but as a reader you you're not told
anything so you have to inquire you have
to have the initiative to see what
happens after that and you're not a part
of the process of development or
purchasing it or bidding on it or
anything like that after you read it
once maybe twice it's out of your hands
and then your supervisors the
coordinators the execs the VP's they're
the ones who are going to be deciding
whether the company is going to option
it or not
that's fastening I wonder where there
are certain scripts that you would read
just the first 10 pages of and you just
knew right away this was not gonna go
anywhere and if yeah why I mean as crazy
as it sounds it could be the first
paragraph it could be the first line I
mean if there's two typos in the first
line like it's probably not gonna go
anywhere you know it's very rare
incredibly rare that the first 10 20 30
pages will be weak and then the script
gets a whole lot better later you know
if a writer doesn't know how to write a
great act one they're not gonna learn
later or suddenly turn it around and
have a great act to a or act to be I
find this fascinating so I was just
curious did you have a cubicle like your
own desk to really like digest this no
it was reading at home a reader is a
totally freelance job so at the time I
mean this really dates me a lot of the
work was actually in print so I would go
to the company that I was working for
they would give me a script or two or a
stack or a book printed on paper I would
go home I would write up the coverage
report and then I would actually really
early on I would put it on a disk on a
floppy disk I would save it and then I
would come back in and give them the
floppy disk and they would put it on
their computer into the server so that
the execs and president of the company
and stuff could access it you know but
yeah I was actually reading on paper now
they obviously just email a PDF and then
it's up to the reader who works at home
whether they want to print it out and
read it on paper or they want to read it
on their computer or tablet or whatever
and what would you say was the average
amount of you know coverage that you
were reading in a 24-hour period for one
thing like you said 600 pages for a book
but that sounds like that maybe was
excessive it was yeah I when I was a
reader it I was in New York City so I
didn't read a ton of scripts at once
like readers in LA
we'll come in and pick up or not pick up
these days but they'll get five or six
scripts at once and they'll have two or
three days maybe four to turn them
around okay so they have to read all
these scripts right coverage reports and
send them back in to their employer
whether it's an agency or a production
company or a studio in my case I never
read that high of a volume but let's say
usually the turnaround was two days so
I'd get a script whether I got a script
or two or three let's say I got them on
Monday they would be due by Wednesday
but what was challenging and good
because it paid more money was the
overnight jobs so if they needed
something overnight I it would be
tougher because I would get less sleep
that night and I would really have to
blast this thing out and send it in in
the morning or let's say by noon if it
wasn't as urgent maybe by the end of the
day the next day but it would pay a
little bit more for overnight jobs so I
always liked those and so what did you
start to learn about really dissecting
something because I mean are you like
speed reading how does one finish
something and then do coverage on it
within a two day period like that well
some readers might take notes as they go
they might write notes in the margins if
they're reading on paper but after a
while I just I just internalized my
thoughts and I actually had what I
called the brain dump which is for that
time period
of when I was focusing on this piece of
material whether 24 hours 48 hours I
would remember everything about it I
mean I would be reading fast but I would
be absorbing everything right and I had
been doing this for a long time so I've
seen the patterns in structure and in
writing and so I know immediately this
is a cliche or this page is too dense
this dialogue is too on the nose
so I'm noting that as I'm reading really
fast even though I'm reading fast I'm
catching these things and then when I'm
done I immediately would write up the
synopsis while it was fresh in my head
and then I would write up my one page of
comments but the interesting thing was
and the reason I call it the brain dump
was the next day or two days later a
week later I didn't remember all that
detail because I was just my brain was
focused on this one 48-hour period you
have to do coverage on this piece of
material so keep it in your brain for 48
hours and then after that dump most of
it you know I mean the great scripts and
the great books that I read on the job
I still do remember you know elements of
them I mean I still remember lines from
like The Sixth Sense script and from a
few other scripts and and some books but
generally a reader is just evaluating it
for one read and it's in that one 24 to
48 hour period they're not doing pages
of pages of notes they're not meeting
with the writer you know this isn't
development they're just evaluating one
read after it comes in the door and
they're handing their report in and then
from there they don't really know where
it goes I'm just curious what were some
common cliches at that time you were
seeing in these scripts well some big
mistakes I would say that I would get in
scripts coming in the door were like big
really big dense blocks of description
just too many words on the page the
worst is when they make the margins
really small so that they can fit more
on the page because they haven't really
tightened the script up enough so with
making the margins tiny and and even the
spacing like the letting you can make
tighter and final draft and in other
screenwriting software's if you do that
the reader immediately knows that you're
cheating and they know that even your
script may say it's a hundred and ten
pages but if you went to normal margins
and normal spacing it would probably be
like 123 or something so readers hate
that you know right off the bat because
you're taking up more of their time and
it also shows that you're an
undisciplined writer who doesn't know
how to write a well-paced script in the
proper spacing and format that
into the average script being let's say
105 210 pages these days so there's that
and then there is takes too long to get
to the inciting incident the inciting
incident should be between page eight to
ten sometimes twelve is okay but we
really need a catalyst you know we need
an inciting incident to happen and then
as well later on you don't want Act one
to be too far into the script it should
be the the break of act 1 and act 2
should be probably around page 30 it
doesn't have to be exactly on page 30
but around page 30 but some beginner
scripts it literally be like page 47
before a really big turn and Direction
happened and it felt like we were in act
2 so those are some examples but the
on-the-nose dialog could be one of the
worst I like to say sometimes that
Talking Heads dialogue where it's just
two characters talking to each other
kind of at each other and then Q&A
sessions are the worst and that's where
one character keeps asking another
questions and then they just keep
answering it so it's almost like an
interview and if that goes on for too
long it really tires out the reader and
it just gets really what we call on the
nose Dan how many screenplays would you
say over the course of your lifetime
you've read I probably over a thousand
I'm not one of those people who's like
I've read five or six thousand dan of
the numerous scripts that you've read
how many would you say went on to become
films very few it's very rare that they
do it's hard for a script to get
optioned or sold and then it's even
harder for it to get produced so it's
very rare and that's why I always say
your script has to be great it can't
just be good it has to be great that's
why I titled my first book how to write
a great screenplay with great and in
caps because working as a reader and now
as a writing coach something really has
to blow me away and because it's so
tough for it to rise up the ladder and
become an option script
old script a produced script so you
really have to come in with something
with a unique voice with a unique
approach to commercially successful
genre it's really tough so I can't
really put my finger on how many became
produced of scripts that I read but it's
few and far between so going back to
when you were you got a BFA at NYU yeah
you were doing this like script reading
and all that from that time when you
went to NYU to the beginning stages of
the script reading job were you aware of
how tough it was or at that time it was
just like you thought that if something
was really good and it was a first time
writer the doors were open I was
probably a bit more naive I probably
thought that more things rose up the
ladder and got bought and greenlit and
produced but after a while I realized
well first things first 9 out of 10
scripts I would pass on I would reject
so I got the sense right away that even
though this was you know on the
professional level and these scripts
were coming from agents and managers and
producers some had major stars attached
but the material just wasn't there it
just wasn't great and so I would pass on
most things 9 out of 10 things so what
was great was as a reader I was always
looking for that thing to say yes to not
to say no to because it was so
exhilarating when I found that one out
of 10 or one out of 20 scripts that
month that really blew me away and
really brought it and excited me and I
was happy to give it a consider or
recommend on the coverage report was it
that black or white was it either a yay
or a nay or was there sometimes a middle
ground where yes but this needs to be
tightened up yeah there's something
called consider with reservations which
is this could be a great movie for my
employer but there's reservations about
it it would be really expensive there's
not a kind of star role in it
it's too long so it need to be cut down
but we're considering it that reader is
considering it because it's great
writing you know and now what's good
about the consider with reservations or
just the consider level evaluation which
because there's passed consider
recommend recommend is really high
recommend is like this is not only great
material but this is ready and perfect
for my employer so this particular
studio this is right in their wheelhouse
it's right in the budget range so I
fully recommend that consider is a
really good grade and any writer should
be excited to get a consider and what it
means is even if that particular piece
of material isn't right for that
production company or that studio the
writer is a good writer and they may
want to work with this writer on another
project so they may want to bring them
in for a meeting see if there's someone
they could work with and then maybe give
them an assignment you know like a
rewrite assignment excellent how often
have you seen an unknown writer be a
recommend come in and they green-lighted
and it actually happens how often does
that happen
well that's very rare I just in general
I probably only gave a handful of
recommends in eight nine years I mean
literally like five or six in each case
I personally didn't know the writer like
one case there was a book by I didn't
know his name at the time I was reading
it but it turns out he was a pretty
well-known writer who written he'd also
written a famous movie and he'd written
some books but at the time he was an
unknown to me because I didn't recognize
his name and so the few times I've had
to recommend they haven't been from
produced named writers they were
basically from unknowns you know they
were writers that I didn't recognize
their names interesting and you found
something about their voice unique yeah
they had a great voice
they had material that was in the
wheelhouse of the studio I was working
for so it was in that John
it was in that budget range it was the
kind of thing they were look they were
looking for when I was working for
Miramax which was headed by Harvey
Weinstein at the time the Weinstein
brothers it was known that Harvey liked
to shoot in Italy so any material that
was set in Italy was to be considered
higher you know was to be given more
attention and so in one case I actually
had development executive give me a book
and say this is set in Italy Harvey
loves Italy he's looking for another
thing to shoot in Italy he just shot
gangs in New York with Scorsese there
and so I really want you to give this a
good evaluation and hopefully you'll
like it and I actually asked her I'm
like do you want me to just give it a
consider you know even if it sucks you
know I help you out here and she's like
no no no I want you to give us your
honest opinion and I read it and it
wasn't good enough and so I passed on it
and I don't know what happened after
that
but she probably wasn't happy with me
it's better that's about it yeah it's
all about the material so and I just
didn't think the material was there so
as a reader you don't know very much
about this writer and is that right I'm
assuming it's yeah you don't know
anything really that's good unless you
recognize the name so yeah the reader
gets no information going in they may
see a cover letter they may see an email
history maybe but not always so if they
happen to see an email history they may
know a little bit about the author you
know this is what the agent has written
back and forth with the development
executive before they actually send the
PDF so the reader may see that but they
probably won't because it's all about
the material is this material strong
enough you know if it's coming from
Aaron Sorkin you may give a little bit
more weight to that because Aaron Sorkin
can get a film made he can write a
greenlit movie but you're still
evaluating on the writing so if Aaron
Sorkin has written something that's not
right for your company or just isn't
at the level of quality that would get a
recommend or consider if that readers
being honest they're gonna pass on it
yeah I'm just wondering how much of your
own personal bias
you know Italy sees someone's picture
you might like them more and then like
their script more you know yeah
or if you know their backstory and then
maybe but you shouldn't do that
you shouldn't have any bias and in my
experience I almost never knew the
backstory of a particular piece of
material so before the interview we were
taking a look at your site and it's
excellent it's AK for screenplays calm
and you have so many interesting parts
to it so we're gonna have some questions
with that one of which is I think
something you wrote where you put in
Hollywood nothing will ever be stronger
than a great story trends come and go
stars rise and fall and studios succeed
and fold but a great story will always
be King and I'm just wondering if you
can talk about you know why story is
king and some of the parts to that
well story is timeless a great script or
great piece of material is timeless it
trends do come and go in film you know
visuals and use of CGI developments with
digital equipment you know all these
things 3d versus 2d now we're getting
the virtual reality but what really
matters is that great story it doesn't
matter how big the budget of a movie is
doesn't matter if it's in 3d or not the
audience is gonna respond if it's a
great movie if it's a great story so a
great piece of material can really blow
away everything you know like think
about an actor they're gonna go through
various levels of popularity they may be
hot right now or not but a great script
is always going to be a great script so
that's really the only currency in
Hollywood that really means something
you know nobody knows anything as
William Goldman famously said about
Hollywood and look at there's been a
number of MU
this year as any year with big stars
that bomb and probably a big reason is
the material you know it's not just that
the stars are hot this year
passengers with basically the two
hottest stars in the world Chris Pratt
and Jennifer Lawrence came out and it
totally bombed and I had heard I haven't
seen it but I've heard from some people
liked and some people didn't but there
was a lot wrong apparently with the
script with the structure of the film
with just the story in general just the
story didn't grab people and it didn't
matter how big the stars were in that
role so it's really the only currency
that you have especially for writers
it's the your only currency is your
material is your spec script whether
it's a spec pilot for a TV series or a
spec feature yeah I find that so
interesting that you know yes story is
king but the writer gets so little
credit and is often not even brought in
on set and so many changes are made
unbeknownst to them so I find that
fascinating but it really does come down
to that story because if you talked
about being a script reader and that
there were a few stories that you still
remember to this day and and how whether
they pulled it's your own sort of
heartstrings or whatever it was that
story really does stay with you can you
think of some films that you you've know
even from a child that just really
stayed with you and maybe they didn't
have huge stars attached maybe they did
well we're talking about a class I just
got two movies on blu-ray that I hadn't
had on blu-ray I just ordered from
Amazon and they are minority Minority
Report and The Wizard of Oz oh the
Wizard of Oz is one of my favorite
movies of all time it's a classic and
but I primarily got it because I wanted
to show it to my nieces and nephews you
know someday if they're we're all
together for Christmas or something I
want to make sure that they see it they
probably will see at some point but just
in case they haven't seen it or even if
they had and it's Christmas and we're
looking for something family-friendly
and I wanted it on blu-ray I want it in
the best quality possible and it's just
it's timeless it's never going to not be
great so
right there it's a generational thing I
want to pass this on to the next
generation now I don't know how old they
have to be before I can show them
Goodfellas you know or if they'll ever
like Goodfellas but I would love to see
if they like Goodfellas someday or
Raiders of the Lost Ark you know sure
wait till College yeah yeah maybe
according to your site ninety-five
percent of great movies follow the story
map I'm curious what is a story map a
story map is a structural template
that's followed by most commercial films
and it breaks a story a film narrative
into four acts act 1 act 2 a act to be
and act 3 and it contains four major
story engines that drive each one of the
individual acts and eight to twelve
major signpost plot beats it's not
deciding what you will write it's
providing a form and a template with
which the writer pours their story into
so a writer still makes their own unique
creative decisions but they may want to
think about what page ranges those
decisions fall in and the kind of basic
beats that would inform the storytelling
okay where do you think many new writers
go wrong in terms of the map in terms of
the layout what where most new writers
weak in that structure often it's over
writing to the point where those beats
are falling too late like I mentioned
the inciting incident should probably be
between eight 8/2 page eight to twelve
but we also want something that I call
the strong movement forward
the next major beat to be in the page 18
to 20 range sometimes that doesn't
happen until 28 and then the true end of
act 1 which should be around page 30 is
in the beginner script not happening
until page 38 and that really makes the
reader anxious and it slows down the
pace of the story and the structure so
it's not hitting the proper
Paige ranges again this isn't deciding
what you should write but it's deciding
basically what page ranges the major
beats should be how you should tell the
story to some extent okay kind of that
outer frame of the story with which
you're pouring your unique unique
decisions into but as far as mistakes
there's a a major signpost beet falling
too early too late or just not being
there for example there's a beet that I
call the assumption of power or
declaration of war beet and this should
happen around page 75 and you can see it
in movies that happens around minute 75
if that's not there if there's not that
moment where this character really feels
their true power and acts in a way that
makes them rise to the occasion and kind
of a declaration of war or an attack and
a declaration of intent and something
that taps their inner strength if that's
not happening in that page range I don't
think the story is necessarily moving as
it should
interesting is there an example of a
film or two that you could just tell us
about like when that moment is that's
fascinating to me yeah the what I call
the declaration of war slash assumption
of power beet is around page 75 in a
screenplay and minute 75 in a film so a
classic example would be in the Karate
Kid the show-me paint
house moment show me paint the fence
show me Sand the floor and it's that
moment at which Daniel Larusso realizes
he's been learning karate all along
even though mr. Miyagi has been making
him do all his chores so he asked him to
show him the the positions that he's put
his hands as he's been doing these
chores and it turns out he's been
learning karate this whole time so he
really Daniel really realizes his true
power realizes he can do karate and he's
doing it already so when you go back to
read scripts that you can tell her from
a more seasoned writer you you say that
you just see it as a tighter
in terms of when you know say that
inciting incident pages 8 through 10 or
it's just it's a more on the nose blows
it flows okay right and then you can
tell maybe someone who's more of a green
rider baby writer by the fact that it's
it's loose or it's either it's either
farther pushed down or too soon or
something
yeah it's overwritten scenes are too
long they dragged on too long you have
those QA sessions of dialogue those
talking-head scenes where there's just
too much on the nose dialogue this is
the scene isn't moving forward you want
every scene to advance the story to
explore the controlling theme or reveal
crucial character okay it has to advance
the story so definitely that first one
it has to do in some way and then
ideally it will also be on theme that
major theme that central theme that this
particular story is exploring and then
third does it reveal some crucial
character you know something that we
haven't seen before about this
particular character so what about the
school of thought where people say you
know it doesn't have to be so on the
nose and then there's others that are
like yes it does
well what's your take on that because we
do cars like page point since right yeah
yeah some people really debate that and
they feel really controlled by that but
it sounds like it's it's incredibly
important because the reader or the
viewer will lose interest I think it is
you know I think structure is very
important in hitting those page points
is important if for no other reason
because every reader
in Hollywood has internalized that
structure but I mean the real proof in
the pudding is that when you read Pro
scripts buy produced writers by the top
writers in Hollywood who are making the
top money they use this structure so
there has to be something about it that
is the reason why the first act of a
movie is around 30 minutes I mean
there's something there there's some
reason why that works well dan we've
pulled a few comments from a few videos
from our YouTube channel and just wanted
to run them by you and see what you
think because they do have the you know
a point just what they're making here
one common is anyone who says there's
not a formulaic process in mainstream
Hollywood movies and movies in general
is kidding themselves we expect a
certain story structure based on a
thousand years of Western storytelling
deviate at your own risk
I would agree with that except it's not
a formula it's a form okay a formula
would dictate what you write a form is
dictating how you structure it at what
point do you reveal things at what point
should the story keep moving forward and
keep flowing rather than stop that in
its tracks or just have a eight page
dialogue scene so it's not formula its
form and I constantly remind my clients
about that and my students it's really
important to understand that interesting
okay I like that
another comment no wonder people are
dissatisfied with Hollywood every movie
is similar and so predictable that the
industry has committed the biggest sin
it is so predictable that it boards one
two tiers story plot lines really are
business plans in disguise instead of
entertainment that can be true and I do
see that being true in kind of more and
more Hollywood movies the franchise
films they are very formulaic and they
are employing the same character arcs of
the same themes like the theme in
animation a lot of times it's the theme
of believe in yourself you can do
anything you know and I think it's it's
more interesting when you see an
animated film that's a little bit more
complex than that it's a little bit more
complicated than that so I personally do
like to see other themes explored and a
little bit more intelligent exploration
of character and theme and I do agree
that a lot of the franchise films are
becoming similar because they're using
similar character arcs and similar
themes and similar plot devices you know
a lot of the action movies today I'm
just so bored by because it's just
battle after battle even something like
like
Logan Logan was very different from a
lot of other superhero films and I think
the audience responded because of that
there was more character there was it
was darker it was it was more mature but
once he starts slashing in those action
scenes I honestly get a little bored
I've seen Wolverine slash with his claws
in what seven eight movies by now maybe
more so those long extended action
scenes and battle scenes and car chases
for me don't interest me as much because
I've seen them in so many movies now
maybe 12 14 15 year olds it is more
interesting and that is a core audience
but a screenwriter shouldn't necessarily
be focused on that 14 15 year-old boy
audience because they already have a
bunch of highly paid writers in
Hollywood who will write those
particular franchise films a
screenwriter breaks in because they have
great characters great dialogue and they
explore themes and interesting ways and
they come up with a new unique take on a
commercially proven genre that's what
you want to do you want to blow away the
reader you want to write a really great
piece of material so that you get your
foot in the door and then they'll hire
you to do those assignments but they
don't necessarily want a new writer to
write a huge franchise film because for
no other reason because those cost so
much they're not going to entrust a
newbie with a 100 million dollar movie
and even if it's a lower budget film you
don't have to write for the lowest
common denominator you should write to
the top of your intelligence and don't
you have a book that you've written
about writing a superhero script I have
a webinar that I've written called
writing the superhero movie and yeah I'm
a huge fan of superhero films and I like
them when they really stand out with
some unique character development and
interesting themes I love most of the
Marvel movies they're getting a little
bit more formulaic in my opinion a
little bit familiar in the themes and
action scenes you know now
but I do love the superhero genre and
I'm always hoping that a writer will do
something new with it we talk about core
formats and that's a term that's new for
me
so what should a writer know about
creating story for each one and I
understand in your book you talk about
the one-hour drama or dramedy 30-minute
single-camera sitcom 30-minute
multi-camera sitcom a 30-minute drama
dihybrid or the web series which is
credibly popular well first things first
write something that you would want to
watch write a format that you love that
you would want to watch so if you prefer
one-hour dramas like Breaking Bad or
madman or something like that then write
one of those ideally you would know
those formats so if you love Breaking
Bad Mad Men The Good Wife then you would
probably know a little bit more about
that format you just internalize a
little bit more about that format and
ideally you want to map out or outline
out several episodes of your favorite
shows before you tackle that first pilot
so you understand the structure a little
bit more and you're not just writing
freeform especially if you're coming
from features because you really need to
understand the TV structure so write
what you know and love and would watch
the 30-minute dramedy tent they tend to
have more of a cultural viewpoint
there's more diversity in the 30 minute
drama tease and they're more they're set
in a more specific world definitely then
definitely more than like a multi-camera
sitcom like a Big Bang Theory for
example it's more of a subculture it's
more of a micro culture and I guess
you'd say a personal viewpoint but the
more personal you can get the more
specific you can get that applies to any
format what do you see many people
venturing into these days like the
webseries is what's been the most
popular 2016-2017 well there are more
one-hour scripted dramas than other
formats actually out there in the
marketplace like
on cable you know on on your TV or on a
screaming service like Amazon or Netflix
so they're more of those but I really
think you should write what you want to
watch so it's really up to you there may
be more 1 hours being made than any
other format but in my opinion the most
interesting and unique and experimental
form today is the 30 minute single
camera show whether it's single camera
sitcom or single camera drama dihybrid
there just is more going on there
there's more unique creator driven
material than ever in that format and I
would like to think that networks are
more open to it and streaming services
are more open to it because it is
cheaper to create to produce a 30 minute
show than a 1-hour scripted show
certainly like a one hour action show or
one hour period piece those are going to
be really expensive so it's cheaper and
some of them come from webseries
something like Issa Rae doing insecure
started as a web series difficult people
was a web series so it's easier to get
in the door with an established
30-minute series what's the first step
in writing a screenplay either for
television or feature film well I think
it's making sure that your concept can
sustain a full feature film or a series
now in TV it's trickier because you not
only need to have a great pilot which is
one episode of your show but you need to
have a concept that can sustain a series
for multiple seasons so you need to have
what a friend of mine called a
playground a dramatic playground which
is you create this very specific world
and then you put these interesting
characters into it to play and to bang
against each other and have lots of
dramatic conflict if that idea is
something that can sustain and run for a
while then maybe that's a better idea
for TV whereas feature films have closed
endings so you're gonna have an idea
with the beginning middle end and that's
pretty much that
let's take the feature film so first
step in writing a screenplay for a
feature film I would say story mapping
it out if you have a concept that you
think is great and you're passionate
about it and you want to write it write
a story map which is your basic outline
so it's going to be your eight to twelve
major signpost beats and your four story
engines and you're gonna define your
core elements first what I call the
basic story map which is your
protagonist they're external and
internal goal the main dramatic conflict
that's standing in the way of that goal
that's gonna that's going to generate
all those obstacles that are really
going to sustain the story you're
controlling theme which is your major
meta theme that you're going to be
exploring and then a few other elements
like your protagonist you want to have
their skill their misbehavior a
misbehavior is a quirk or personality
trait that consistently generates
conflict and then their Achilles heel
which is just that thing that could
destroy them could potentially destroy
them so once you have those core
elements and then you have the major
sound signpost beats of your outline
then you're ready to do a full scene
outline and then jump in and write pages
what's the first step in writing a
screenplay for a TV series I would
always say start the story as late as
possible enter the story as late as
possible so you don't have too much set
up and so that the story can get going
right away okay do you think sometimes
new writers they they again they
overwrite and it's too dense and they're
just kind of like giving us too much
backstory yeah yeah too much setup you
don't need that much setup maybe you're
opening with a flash-forward like in
Breaking Bad it's like boom were in this
really tense scene where there's this
guy in his underwear driving an RV like
a bat out of hell and he has a gas mask
on and he crashes the RV and in the
script he was called underwear man
before we find out found out his name
was Walter White but they just boom
dropped us right into the action and
that's something that
really grabs a reader can we talk about
the difference in creating a fascinating
protagonist for film versus television
or maybe it's the same for film I think
it's gonna be affected by that closed
ending because there arc is going to arc
over the course of this 90 to 120 minute
film or ninety two hundred and ten page
screenplay and then it's going to end
basically and that's where we're gonna
leave the character whereas a TV
protagonist they have to be able to go
through various arcs over the course of
years you know it may be on for ten
seasons so there needs to be the
potential for that kind of growth now
you don't need to know what's going to
happen to this character for 10 seasons
but it would be good to know the basics
of what will happen like in the first
two or three seasons for example any
examples of characters well if you give
your protagonist a lot of emotional
baggage then there's gonna be a lot to
unpack you know over time something like
carry from homeland she's bipolar and
she is reckless in her behavior and she
starts an affair with this guy that
she's supposed to be tracking that's a
potential terrorist in season one so
she's kind of a mess and so there's
definitely gonna be drama with her going
forward or or Don Draper from Mad Men he
has the secret personality from the past
and he has the secret that he's keeping
who what is his true identity that's
always a risk to come out to destroy him
so if you keep some kind of element
there some kind of Achilles heel always
there and ready to destroy them then
you're gonna get a lot of seasons of
material out of that hero let's talk
about for a feature film because you
said there's that that closure so what
what makes can you give any examples of
an interesting protagonist could be
current film could be yeah a classic
example of a great character arc
would be Indiana Jones and Raiders of
the Lost Ark you know that first Indiana
Jones film his Ark is to accept the
supernatural he doesn't believe in
anything supernatural or spiritual he
doesn't believe in God okay so when he
gets this mission to find the Ark of the
Covenant he doesn't he just thinks it's
a relic you know he doesn't think that
it's actually something that could have
any kind of power
his final fruition of the Ark is when he
respects let's say God's power and the
power of the Ark and he shuts his eyes
and he tells Marion to shut her eyes
once the Ark has been open and the power
of the art kills all the Nazis but does
not hurt him and Marion because they've
respected God and not looked at the face
of God so it's not just him in a fight
you know you would think it's an action
movie non-stop action it would be him
fighting the head Nazi it's not at all
and that's what makes it such an
interesting choice for the character and
to close the film it's him respecting
the spiritual world you talk about when
you went to Tisch for film and
television
what was the curriculum regarding
writing at that time
and if you were to take it today and
teach a class there what would you add
to it what would you change keep the
same well there wasn't a ton of
screenwriting when I was there my
favorite class was screenplay analysis
you know in the no shocker there the
first produced screenplay that I read
was in that class we read the Silence of
the Lambs which was a really great
script and it was interesting because
that script was exactly 120 pages and
they always say one page equals one
minute so it was exactly 120 minutes two
hours and that got me thinking hmm how
would this writer and know that he's
going to end exactly two hours in 120
pages in and that and then in the course
of the class we learned about structure
and how important structure was and that
it was structured exactly to end on page
120 you said there were too many classes
on writing there and of course the ones
that were I'm yeah you you you loved how
would you expand on it
knowing today's you know landscape in
terms of these different sort of core
formats mm-hmm what would you add to the
curriculum let's say they invited you to
come back as a teacher professor well I
think I would definitely emphasize
television the long-form scripted
television writing form and I would
probably emphasize low-budget filmmaking
writing something that could be shot on
a low budget
now films are being shot on iPhones and
they're getting released in theaters and
they're getting nominated for awards and
winning awards so I would go in and tell
these kids they probably already know it
but you can shoot a movie on anything on
any topic on any type of equipment and
if it's good and it has a great story it
could have an afterlife but it still has
to have that great story so it doesn't
matter what technology you use I would
say learn about screenwriting and learn
about structure and focus on the writing
first and in terms of the actual
breakdown of writing a screenplay what
do you think you would focus on more in
terms of structure or dialogue or like
for students yeah if you were to be come
back as a professor and have say with
the curriculum I mean I would most
definitely focus on structure the most I
think just flowing short tight
storytelling you know there's nothing
better than a two-page scene that really
advances the story and surprises us and
you know brings up a turn and direction
and shows us an element of the character
that we didn't see coming you know it's
all about surprised and subverting our
expectations that's why it's so
important not to have cliches because
the audience that the reader doesn't
want to know what's going to happen
because it's compelling if they're
surprised so I would probably emphasize
that structure and surprising
storytelling not cliche storytelling so
you went into the program thinking about
the industry and knowing there were
certain films that you wanted to
in a similar genre and similar voice
when you came out of the program what
did the real world show you what was an
eye-opener what was maybe a
disappointment what was more of an
unplanned sort of joyous discovery about
the industry well it took me a while to
realize that working in the industry at
a day job you don't have to be creative
they don't want you to be creative
unless you're in a creative position so
I was so obsessed with with selling a
screenplay and directing my first film
when I was in my early 20s and I was
doing my first day jobs as you know
interns as a administrative assistant as
a reader and I was always looking for a
way to impress the boss so that they
would eventually bankroll my film or buy
my script and what I didn't realize was
it was all about just working hard put
your head down work harder than the next
guy and then if you work hard enough and
they believe in you because you've
worked so hard and shown that initiative
and taken any job out there no matter
how you know any task they give you no
matter how bad or ugly or gross or
whatever take that job do the best job
you can at it do it 120 percent and
that's what's gonna get you hired that's
what's gonna get you the better position
to move up the ladder so when you say
they don't necessarily want people that
are creative that's interesting so even
if you're a fantastic writer it doesn't
necessarily mean you're gonna get a
certain job where writing skills aren't
maybe at the forefront of what you're
doing mm-hmm yeah like if you're working
in development your job is to evaluate
material and develop material for your
employers company you know it's not to
write your own script it's to find
material and find material that's right
for your employer and then develop that
material so that it can be a greenlit
film so if you're a screenwriter working
in development let's say you're an
assistant to create
director or director of development at a
studio they don't want you to be writing
your screenplay
you know two hours of the day they want
you to support them and finding great
material elsewhere do you think
internships are good for someone coming
out of film school yeah I definitely
think so it can be challenging because
how do you pay your rent if you're
working at a free internship you know
and that's one that's one challenge that
I had as well I used to do temp work I
still do administrative assistant temp
work at the time and try to do
internships at the same time which was
challenging
oh but yeah definitely internships but
the main advice is just work hard work
harder than the next guy that sounds
like a lot how did you juggle that well
it was tough I would try to get temp
jobs I would tell my supervisors that
the temp company that I wanted jobs that
were only like one two or three days and
then hopefully that would make me enough
money maybe for a couple weeks and then
those two or three days that I wasn't
working that week I would go into the
internship at the film company Oh
interesting it was tough but I figured
it out somehow so you have a mantra on
your site which is act for screenplays
calm and the mantra is craft equals
business which means focus on your craft
first and foremost and the commercial
success will follow and I was wondering
if we could expand on that yeah it's
more important to write a great script
than it is to worry about what door
you're gonna get it in you know to worry
about the commercial aspect the
marketing aspect focus on writing a
great piece of material and that will
open doors for you so don't worry too
much about writing for the market it is
something that you should consider I
mean you don't want to write a
three-hour drama set in 1903 about you
know a grandma and her dog maybe unless
it's the greatest thing you could ever
think of you probably do want to write
something that's a little bit more for
today's commercial marketplace but your
main job is to write a great script
that's going to blow
way that and reader I know you I think
you'd also said that you know if you try
to play to the market by the time you
get that story out there and go through
meetings that trend will have sailed
yeah it's very possible that that
particular trend will be gone by the
time you finally finish this get it in
professional quality you know highest
quality to really blow away that reader
and really move up the ranks and an
example that would be there was a big
fairy tale trend in Hollywood in film
and TV a few years ago and it's pretty
much dead now because they bought so
much material and so now you probably
should think twice about writing a new
take on a fairy tale doesn't mean you
can't it doesn't mean you couldn't write
a great thing on that but you should
probably check with the industry to see
if there hasn't already been a script
with that similar premise like let's say
you have a new take on Goldilocks and
the three bears for example check with
people that you know in development to
see that maybe there weren't three
Goldilocks and the three bears specs
floating around five years ago and two
of them were already bought and are
sitting in the you know coffers of the
studios and then if you don't know
anyone in development let's suppose you
you haven't made those contacts yet is
there a way could you look through the
trades I would say yeah I look through
the trades you know Hollywood Reporter
Variety deadline.com so look through the
trades there's certain certain websites
that might have a little bit more
insight into the industry just try and
do whatever research you can and just
like timing the market is is difficult
in whatever sort of market you're trying
to enter into and finding that next big
trend I mean that's like the million
dollar question in any industry yeah
don't worry about it
don't worry about it you're writing a
writing sample most as a newbie you're
mostly writing a writing sample that
shows your talent that shows your voice
that shows your writing quality and that
will get you picked up by a manager or
an agent
and they're gonna have you write more
scripts that will then maybe those will
be the pieces of business those will be
the things that sell but that first high
quality writing sample that you write
that's going to get the industry
interested in you it's more about the
writing than about the sale ability I
love it so once someone gets this agent
or manager though I see a lot of people
resting on their laurels and thinking
okay well now I have representation so
I'm going now but it's not it sounds
like you're still doing exactly the same
thing yeah you're still writing writing
writing you're only as good as your last
script and you need to have a portfolio
of scripts not you don't have 10 scripts
ready to go but a few scripts ready to
go in case you're in a meeting and you
say hey I've got this action script that
I wrote you know two years ago or two
weeks ago and they really like the idea
they really want to read it so you have
to have that ready to submit you know
you want to have different scripts in
your portfolio so that they're ready to
submit at any any moment and knowing
that someone that's a new writer will
not be as high a priority with their
agent and manager how much should they
be in contact with them and how
proactive should they be because I feel
like if someone's not proactive enough
they're gonna drown in the sea of all
the other calls and emails this person
good I don't know that's a tough
question but I would say one lesson
there is it's not their job to get all
of your submissions you should be
networking as well even if you have good
representation you should be finding
submissions and then you tell them to
send your script and they they will
email it and so it'll kind of be on
their letterhead so it's an official
submission so you do need to be
proactive and find places to submit your
script and to make connections and shake
hands and get face time with potential
buyers but then you have representation
to send them the script and they'll read
it because you have legal representation
whether it's a lawyer agent or manager
so really almost be in the mindset of I
don't have someone representing me in
terms of finding me work but then once I
do find that sort of nugget where I can
try to submit to that then I can put it
on their letterhead and I look more you
know it's it's not even that you look
better having a rep it's that in a lot
of cases big companies do not accept
unwrapped material they don't accept
unsolicited material so unless it's
coming from a lawyer a manager or an
agent they won't read it and they say
they can't read it for liability reasons
so it's really important that you get
yourself a rep dan if we were to delve
into the mind of most new writers
whether they live in LA or or they're
living somewhere else do you think that
they view a lot of their work as a
sample or a series of samples or are
they seeing it as the next big thing
that Wow
once it's discovered this thing is
taking LA and New York London by storm
definitely London yeah
not as many scripts get bought as used
to be so I think it's imperative that
they think of it more as a writing
sample of their work yeah too many new
writers are thinking I'm gonna sell this
for six figures and I can live off that
for the next ten years you know and I'm
gonna sell a whole bunch more scripts in
that in in the meantime but they don't
buy as many scripts as they used to and
it's a really really competitive market
especially for newbies so I think it's
best if you think of it more as a
writing sample but yeah I do see a lot
of writers who are trying to write for
the market and they're trying to write
something that they think Hollywood will
buy because Hollywood makes a lot of
those types of movies but unfortunately
they're borrowing formulas and cliches
from those movies and that's not the
right thing to do on the page on the
page you still need to really impress
that reader and have something unique
bring something to the table let's say
I'm a new writer and I'm very precious
about something and I've written and
it's very close to my heart it's very
emotional I've been able to get a chance
to present it
and I've been told this is a great
sample and now I'm hurt I'm angry my
hopes are dashed okay where do I go from
here well if you've been told you mean
it you've been told it's a great sample
but it's rejected or your manager says
I'm gonna send this out as a great
sample to get you jobs let's suppose
they sent it out to get me jobs and then
we've been told this is a great sample
but this isn't gonna work
and what else do you have and let's
let's start getting more samples you're
not ready yet you're right you you're
you're this is not the end all right
hear that you thought it was well I mean
first cross that bridge when you get to
it you know it only takes one great
script to get your foot in the door and
that's gonna happen you're gonna get
rejected
way more often than they're gonna say
this is a great script and I want to
work with you so you got to have a thick
skin you have to get used to that
rejection and the name of the game is to
find that one champion in the business
for that particular script that you have
and four out of five people are gonna
pass on it 9 out of 10 Studios that you
send it to are gonna pass on it so it's
your job to find that one champion
executive or producer or agent that is
willing to go all the way with it that
is willing to push push past that
rejection over and over until the point
where it does get option or sold or made
as a cheap movie that's funded on
Kickstarter by a really talented
director okay so then let's suppose we
keep sending it out and my take is they
just don't get it they don't understand
where I'm coming from they don't believe
in this material Hollywood just wants to
make these things that no one really
cares about there's no heart and soul am
I too sensitive for the industry do I
just really need to be honest with
myself about the work I'm creating I
think you should take some time away put
it in the drawer metaphorically take
some time away from it do some thinking
and it's your job to keep writing so if
you only want to write this one script
then yeah you are in the wrong place
you're in the wrong business so you have
to keep writing and writing and
producing material hopefully you have at
least one other idea that you want to
write that hopefully is a little bit
more commercial but you just have to
keep writing and you have to keep
pushing past rejection and yeah it is
tough and it's dog-eat-dog so if you
don't have the thick skin for it then
maybe it's not the business for you well
what if I know that I'm sensitive but I
still want to be in the industry I mean
it's it's a realization that you know we
find out things about ourselves we don't
necessarily want to be a certain way but
what if we say okay so I can't submit my
own work because I'm so precious about
it and it makes me so infuriated to know
that I can't get it made but what else
can I do in the industry where it's not
as personal well I think you just should
produce it yourself I think you should
produce your work like for example you
could take your feature and you could
cut it up into 10-minute webisodes for
example and put it on YouTube put it on
Vimeo and produce something put
something out into the world rather than
just keep getting rejected and if you
feel like you're too sensitive to keep
getting rejected well at least at the
end of the day you've produced this and
you have something you know something of
quality that you're proud of and it
could potentially get either people to
reconsider the script or reconsider you
as someone who could who could
potentially write an assignment and what
about other jobs where there might be
more of a steady paycheck coming in well
there's tons of jobs in the industry if
you want to go into production you know
start as a PA there are jobs and
development offices there's jobs I see
jobs listed all the time on LinkedIn
there's a lot of jobs for social media
coordinators at various companies I see
Netflix and Amazon
even like commercial production
companies and a lot of companies
involved with entertainment so I mean I
don't know if I could say a specific job
for a sensitive writer what they would
do but I would say look on LinkedIn
there's actually a lot of jobs in the
entertainment industry dan this isn't a
fully fleshed out question but I'm just
want to throw this out at you so on your
website you say theme is why you tell
the story structure is how you tell it
structure is gonna be the storytelling
aspect how you tell the story where do
you start the story where do you enter
the narrative do you use flash for words
or flashbacks or do you just use a very
straightforward linear structure you
know there's a thousand decisions that
go into how you order your signpost
beats and how long their scenes are
gonna be and what your midpoint is gonna
be and all that but theme is why you're
telling this story what is passionate to
you that you're writing about what is
this central idea that you're exploring
that you are interested in that you feel
like this narrative is supporting and
exploring so your story should really
explore your meta theme that you really
love that you're passionate about that
you think is interesting enough to
sustain a feature or a series and it
really should seep into every scene of
your script ideally and then structure
is how you're going to tell the story in
terms of your scene order how long each
act is gonna be how long each scene is
gonna be where you enter the story where
you leave the story where you enter each
scene and where you leave each scene so
those kind of decisions go into
structure how does a screenwriter know
when it's time to sell their screenplay
well you want to show it to a bunch of
friends you want to get notes from
friends who know screenwriting who know
movies and can give you know how to give
notes on a script so ideally you're in a
writers group and you've gotten feedback
from your writers group you've written I
would say at least five or six drafts
the writing is rewriting as we know
and hopefully maybe you've shown it to
someone who's in the industry not as a
submission but as a friend read where
they've given you some feedback so
there's really no way to know exactly
when you're going to be ready to bring
something to market but basically field
test it with as many people as you can
to the point where you feel like it's in
its best shape possible
okay let's suppose friends family say oh
this is excellent now we know that they
have their reasons for saying it as well
and they don't wanna hurt our feelings
they want to see us do well let's
suppose we're ready to try to go out
there and take it to market what are
some of the first things what are some
websites that we can go to well what can
we do to try to help sell it well I
think you should make a hit list of
companies and people that you're gonna
send your script to I mean first of all
it's good to get a rep so you want to
send it to managers that accept
unsolicited submissions
I believe the writers guild has a list
of those there's a website called the
tracking board where you can probably
find some good manager lists but I
always say pick up the phone that's the
big thing now we don't make as many
phone calls as we used to it you know it
makes us all a little nervous and if
you're a skittish writer who's more of
an introvert that's tough but you have
to pick up the phone and you can
actually get submissions just free cold
calling and introducing yourself and
being nice and saying hey here's what my
scripts about here's the long line do
you want to read it now they may shut
you down right away and say we don't
accept any unsolicited submissions but
they may love it and they can send you a
waiver form that you can sign to where
you can submit without a rep but that's
only if they've heard your logline
they've heard your pitch and they really
like it and they want to read it hi
thank you for waiting I'm sorry to say
this again I'm wondering if I can send
my screenplay to you actually no I'm
wondering if I can have my manager send
my screenplay to you I think maybe
someone at your company would be
interested because it is in spirit and
theme similar to this award-winning film
that you made and I just won an award at
the XYZ contest for my script ok great
I'm gonna transfer you to mr. Smith's
voicemail and you can leave a message
okay and so hey this is mr. Smith dah
dah dah dah dah please leave a message
I'm away from my desk deep hey this is
Joe screenwriter thank you for
considering me and my screenplay I have
an action comedy and I have come and
I've placed in two contests and I really
think you guys might be interested in it
and I would like to know if I can have
my manager Joe Joe at XYZ management
company send it over to you could you
have someone there call me and then give
your phone number and your email as well
excellent
and you know it's luck of the draw who
knows but is it great to maybe have it
all written down what you're going to
say so you don't get thrown off yeah I
think so yeah have your script ready you
definitely want to have your logline
ready or your short elevator pitch right
there's a little fly right right yeah
because I think sometimes that's half
the battle is like calling and you don't
literally have a script it's almost like
you're a telemarketer in some ways and
and then they sense it and then they're
like you know what sorry they shut you
down but I feel like if you've done it
enough times even if you've been
rejected they they're less likely to
totally cut you off ya have a script
ready practice it do it you know a few
times and you can do it under fire on
the job I mean called let's say you have
a list of 10 production companies that
you want to submit to start with the two
or three that are lowest on your list so
they're kind of you're just gonna
practice with them right and you just
practice your sales pitch which is what
it is but you want to compliment them on
their work you want to highlight what is
good about you so let's say you have
written an action comedy about an EMT
write an emergency driver and you happen
to be an EMT then that's something boom
you should say right away
that you have a particular occupation or
experience that makes that lends itself
to this material and gives it more
credibility and then if you have contest
wins or placements if you have any kind
of accolades if you have any kind of
personal connection like even if you
just went to a panel and you saw a
production executive from a certain
studio on this panel you can call and
that might be your opening hey I saw I
saw Joe Morgan on the panel at the AFI
and I really thought he gave some really
great advice and he mentioned at the end
that he would love to find a great
action buddy comedy and I happen to have
one and it just placed in the North
Carolina screenplay contest can I tell
you a little bit more about it so and
then you tell them more about it you
give them your logline
and then they decide whether it sounds
like something they're interested in or
not and maybe you're super nervous and
so they shut you down because of that
maybe you don't have an agent manager or
lawyer you know to send it in maybe they
shut you down for that but you should
because if you don't have an agent or a
manager just find a lawyer who can send
it in okay and you can find a lawyer
somebody must know a lawyer they may
charge you a little money I don't know
you know how how ethical that is but
they may say hey I'll do your script
submission for $40 or something if it
means that much to you and you know that
this person is is a great person in a
great company
maybe that's worth it to you maybe it's
not I don't know
in what ways can a writer improve their
dialogue listening practice I mean just
keep writing keep rewriting have actors
read it out loud I mean they don't have
to be professional actors but just you
and a friend read it out loud listen to
how it flows I think that can be really
helpful
I like that listening where are we
listening listening to how people talk
listening to interesting people around
how they talk and then once you write
your dialogue read it out loud you know
do a table read with friends or your
writers group or just even if you read
it out loud yourself find it interesting
that a lot of times people certain
people end their sentences with right or
you know like and they they continually
do that is that important because even
though that's not you know if you can
get actually irritating after a while
but there's certain people that that's
how they sort of they always want
validation for what they're saying so
it's right right I women do that a lot
and I must say that about my own gender
so we do a lot of right right because we
want people to know that they hurt us
and they got what we said do we infuse
things like that into a script or is
that become too repetitive
well you want each character to sound
unique to themselves you know ideally if
you covered up the character's name and
read the line you would be able to tell
that it was that specific character
because they should have a specific
voice and yeah if you have a character
who needs validation and every sentence
you know ends with right or is that okay
or good then you would write that you
know but in listening to how real people
talk it doesn't mean you're transcribing
it exactly you know people don't talk
like they're in a movie but so there is
a certain amount of you know dramatic
license that you have to use but you can
write to cinematically you know you can
write to theatrically into too much like
your characters are on stage and that
can come through on the page and that
can really hurt your script
can you give me an example of that I
find that interesting cuz I've
definitely seen that in films where it
doesn't feel real good well I would say
to writers that do that a lot would be
Aaron Sorkin and David Mamet but that's
their style and they've been around for
years and they can get away with it you
know and they write produce movies so
when we go see an Aaron Sorkin or David
Mamet film we know that that's the style
of dialogue that they're going to employ
it's gonna be a little bit more poetic a
little bit more about speeches a little
bit more you know stage II but we know
that about their style any writers that
have impeccable dialogue where you you
just feel like they're real people and
you're in a restaurant overhearing
someone in another table have an
interesting conversation that's a good
question I like I like Paul Thomas
Anderson any of the any of the Best
Screenplay winners of recent years you
know they all have really great scripts
I would say Diablo Cody sometimes can
get a little bit too too stylized for
stage II but in general I think she has
a really good really good voice for her
characters are very distinct and it's
just important to find an interesting
way to express an idea even if it's a
simple idea an example that would be in
pulp fiction there's a moment where the
Bruce Willis character goes to buy some
cigarettes and he says to the bartender
he says one pack of red apples and the
bartender says filters and he says none
and that's just a really cool fast
interesting exchange there as opposed to
five lines to explain what brand of
cigarettes he wants and oh you know what
how about no filters in those cigarettes
you know because it's very Norrish feel
it's very you know clipped and dark and
tight and it's just filters none
and that just gets the the idea across
so if I'm a new writer and I'm calling
you about a consultation you know what
can I expect what are some of the first
few things you do with my script
well I'm gonna read it definitely more
than once I'm gonna read it two or three
times I'm gonna give you very detailed
page notes down to even things like line
editing or suggesting that you cut this
line I even I'm I'm obsessive about
typos and spelling errors so I'm
probably also gonna note those but very
detailed notes and the main thing that
I'm doing is I'm giving you my real-time
reactions to your scripts and the
questions in my head
as I have them at the moment I have them
so I'm gonna take your PDF and I'm going
to embed notes in the exact moment where
I had that question or that confusion
for example now in some cases I'll have
a question like why is this character
talking I thought he wasn't in the room
right and then half a page later that's
explained but I leave in the question
because another reader might have that
question and you should know that there
was a confusion at the top of that scene
that it wasn't expressed correctly you
didn't show us that Joe Blow was in that
scene so when he started talking it was
confusing to me so you should know that
the next time you rewrite that scene
even though it's if I was reading fast
the answer to that question would be
clear half a page down but I want to I
want it to be clear now you know you
don't want to confuse the reader so
these are gut reactions that it's
important that you write them down as
you read it for the first time yeah yeah
and it's important that you see as the
writer you see what reactions a reader
is going to have in real time to your
script
and then the next element is is that
follow-up meeting you know it's very
important to have that dialogue whether
it's Skype or phone or in person to
where you can bounce ideas off me ideas
about rewriting and improving your
script you know or even you have a new
concept that you want to that you want
to workshop a little bit and we'll talk
about it and
it just really is a great way to get
ideas out and to kind of feel test ideas
that one-on-one interaction is this PDF
something that you're doing on your own
away from the screenwriter or are they
there in real time no I'm doing it on my
own so I'm acting as a reader they sent
me their material and then I read it on
my own time okay now if they're coming
in from scratch like let's say they want
to write a feature and all they have is
an idea or two or they want to write a
pilot and they only have an idea or two
that's gonna be more of an ongoing
coaching situations so we might do what
I call my eight-week story map master
class and I have a structured course
with weekly lectures and assignments and
you get your lecture on Tuesday and then
your assignment is due on Monday so it
keeps you on track it keeps you on
schedule you have those those you know
core deadlines because you're probably
like me you probably procrastinate and
you really need that deadline and I'm
gonna read your material every single
week no matter what your assignment is
whether it's a story map or whether it's
ten new pages of script I'm gonna read
it and I'm gonna give you feedback and
then we'll have a Skype and we'll
discuss it so you can develop something
completely from scratch with my
professional input so it's a virtual
class but then you're meeting Skype
face-to-face yeah to go over things yeah
and a lot of my clients are from all
over the world so it has to be primarily
by email but then Skype is great you
know we get to see each other and talk
to each other so when you give people
notes what are some of the common
hiccups that they come back to you with
either to combat the note or to say well
I agree but maybe you missed what I was
doing here well I have one client who is
really stubborn I won't say that I can
give her a note like I this is on the
same draft she's a coaching client so
we're going I'm coaching her through
multiple drafts of something and she's
really stubborn about taking certain
notes and I will tell her like look this
doesn't this isn't clear this doesn't
make
since this line totally sticks out and
the next draft she'll still have that
line of dialogue in there and the next
drafts will still have it in there now
eventually she usually takes my note and
usually trust me but she just has that
stubborn thing where she wants to do it
you know her way the way she did it the
first time but writing is rewriting and
you know some things may change
everything they change and I'm not the
final you know I'm not the final judge
of everything I'm not representative of
the entire industry I'm just one guy but
it's important to be open to notes you
know to consider them to talk about
specific like specific ways in which
they disagree and try to fight for a
note or something like that
yeah and and i mean i think that's
pretty specific in terms of you know how
they have trouble accepting a certain
line of dialogue that doesn't belong
because i think we see what we're going
for and we think that everyone else is
going to see it the same way and so it
is difficult for someone to have an
outsize perspective when we're very
emotionally attached to one line yeah a
way of the story is going it's tough and
I know that you know because I write as
well it's tough to take critique I
applaud anyone who is gonna take my
critique and take notes but you have to
have a thick skin and you have to be
able to take it and decide if you want
to use that note and rewrite it in a
certain way that I'm suggesting but I'm
only one opinion I tell this to my
clients all the time I'm one guy I'm not
representative of the whole industry or
a sector of the industry it's up to you
if you want to accept or not accept a
note that I give you and it's okay if
you don't you know it's your baby at
what point is someone ready for a
consultation and at what point are they
not well they should have written I
would say at least two drafts you know
don't send me the absolute first draft
version of your script and I think it's
if you feel like you're not sure if
something is at the level of submission
you know that you want to submit it you
know that you want to send it to a
test or to a professional company but
you're not quite sure if it's at the
right level yet you know and the
flipside of that is maybe it is ready
for submission in that case I will give
you a free referral to somebody that I
know in the business I will pass your
script on if it's already of that
submission quality but as you probably
know 99% of the time it's not ready yet
and that's when I come in and I can
really help a writer to really polish it
up and get it to that level what do you
recommend to a writer that's too much of
a perfectionist and on the flip side one
that's too loose and maybe a little
sloppy if you're too much of a
perfectionist you need to understand
that you need to get it out the door at
a certain point or drop that script and
move on to another a writer writes they
write more than one script you can't
obsess over the same script for years
I've done it everybody does it you know
if it's your baby and you want it to be
perfect it's good that you want to be
super detail-oriented and you want it to
be of a high quality level and not have
any typos or spelling errors and really
blow away the readers so it's gonna take
some time to write it's going to take
years for you to get the skills to write
that great breakthrough script but you
have to get it out the door at some
point or drop it and move on so if
you're planning to get it out the door
then you have to cut it off at some
point and say I'm going to submit this
to a contest or a manager or a producer
or whoever and it's tough it's tough to
get it out the door because you're never
sure if it's exactly ready you know but
it's probably never gonna be perfect
it's probably never going to be the
exact submission ready level that that
needs to be it's just it's subjective
you know to the reader so it's hard to
say okay this is absolutely where you
should cut it off and you should send it
out the door it's your choice and it's
one of the toughest choices for writers
you know when do you submit Dan what
about the writer that's too loose -
sloppy doesn't totally check everything
it's going to be fine because there's
there almost like two of the same two
sides of the same coin mm-hmm well
that's where a consultant like me can
really help you know can really tell you
okay this is not a professional level
quality there I was confused and in
places I really felt like scenes went on
way too long I felt like these voices
weren't authentic and dialogue so I'm
the kind of person a writing coach a
story consultant who can really help
someone like that and really guide them
to improve their craft so both of those
traits perfectionist loose kind of non
detail-oriented what does that stem from
where where does it stem from where you
fall on the spectrum now I'm wondering
how does someone become a perfectionist
and how does somebody become kind of
loose you know sort of kind of lazy lazy
writer I'm not even sure if it's lazy
but they don't seem to care as much
about details because I think they don't
matter mm-hmm maybe they're willing to
spend time on stuff that does matter so
they're not lazy in that respect but in
terms of tying up loose ends they think
that they'll understand you know there's
just some people that flow with certain
things in one way and are more
controlled in other ways and where does
that where does that come from well I
think it comes from your personality and
I think it comes from your own personal
experience how you approach creative
work but it is a craft and it's gonna
take a long time to learn that craft and
to really perfect it and to write your
best work to find your voice and write
the best thing that you were born to
write that's gonna take time and if you
are really loose and what you might call
lazy just you're not detail-oriented
you're not specific you don't care if if
the scene is confusing because it makes
sense to you well that's gonna be a
problem because the reader cares because
the reader wants it to make sense and
wants it to be tight
and wants it to have a really great arc
and surprise and subvert their
expectations and wants it to just be
great so
if you are a really loose writer than
maybe screenwriting is not quite the
discipline for you then the flipside of
one that can't let it go because there's
just too many variables that they've got
to make sure right but then it the life
is squeezed out because it's so it's so
tight it can become drier the more you
pick at it and pick at it you know I
can't say specifically which draft you
know does that happen like okay between
draft 12 and 15 it's gonna get way too
dry and you're gonna lose that original
essence you know but there is that
instance in which someone picks at
something and picks at something
rewrites it so many times takes every
single note they get from every friend
and every consultant and it ends up just
kind of bleeding it dry and you lose the
essence of the original idea the
original concept you know what made you
passionate about that so that's a that's
a pitfall to to look out for you know
Dan on your site I think you have a beat
sheet that you offer it's like a PDF
when people buy my book I offer a
worksheet a story map worksheet that
they can use to map out their own pilot
for example and what makes my book
unique story maps TV drama the structure
of the one-hour television pilot is that
it offers the first detailed beat sheet
for television there's been a lot of
books about feature screenwriting which
offer that paradigm that kind of Syd
field paradigm he's the one who really
started it and no one had yet done it
for TV and I kept getting clients asking
me well do you have a story map for TV
and I went out there and looked and
there wasn't one so I decided to make
one but I decided to develop it from
watching great pilots great shows and
from reading produce pilots even some
that weren't that didn't make it to
series you know stuff that was going
around Hollywood that I could get my
hands on that had actually sold so I
developed a speech heat it's broken down
into acts it's broken down into paid
ranges I give you examples of the page
ranges of many pilots like hit the
Breaking Bad pilot if you read the
actual script the teaser was two pages
Act one was eight pages Act three was
six pages you know just something
hypothetically and I break down where in
those acts were those specific beats
things like the first trial or first
casualty or the end of Act one turn or
the midpoint or the assumption of power
and I'm getting a lot of people saying
that they loved it for that reason that
this was the first time they found a
beachy for television so it's giving
them a roadmap to write their script
it's giving them that chassis of the car
to put their details inside and I've
started actually getting produced
writers telling me that they're using it
as well
I just had a producer from HBO Latino
who lives in Mexico City call me and say
that they're using it now for their show
that's in the fourth season on HBO
Latino and that was really cool that was
really exciting to hear you know so
people are really using my beach scene
and my paradigm excellent can you share
one or two other tips from the beach
sheet it's up to the writer how to break
it down you may do a teaser plus four
act structure you may do a teaser plus
five act structure if you're writing a
30-minute script you may do four acts
you may do a teaser plus two acts it
really depends on you the best way to
know how you should structure your
script and how you should break down the
page ranges you know the timing
basically of that script is to watch
shows that are similar to yours they
tell the story in the same way that
you're gonna tell your TV series okay
and so outline those shows as you watch
them and see how they break up the X if
it's a commercial driven Network like a
broadcast network that has commercials a
lot of those act breaks are going to
correspond to commercial breaks but not
always and not always in the script so
if you can get your hands on the actual
screenplays for pilots that's great as
well
how could someone get that there are if
you just do Google searches you will
find those there's a site name tracking
board where they have a number of
downloads for features the around
Academy Award time each each studio has
their Academy award-nominated scripts or
you know nominated for WGA Awards and
such for awards consideration you can
download those PDFs TV is a little bit
harder to find but they are out there if
you go to forum sites maybe like the
blacklist site for example you will find
people who will have these scripts and
they can send you pilots the beat sheet
is it just for the pilot or is it for
the entire season it's up to you that's
actually a good question there's a
difference between a premise pilot and a
third episode pilot a premise pilot is a
pilot that takes the entire length of
the script to set up and it's more of an
origin story of that character so we're
starting more at the beginning like for
example if it was scandal we might if it
was a premise pilot we would start with
Olivia Pope like in law school or in
college and then we would follow her
over the years to the point where she
opened her own firm or maybe you would
wait until the end of season 1 for her
to open her own firm ok but what they
actually do is a third episode pilot
which is the structure of the pilot uses
the same structure that the for example
third episode of the series would use so
it uses the same structure as every
episode going forward and that's your
decision as a writer but in the example
of scandal she's already a Washington DC
fixer
she's already really successful she
already owns her own company and she has
her own team she even knows the
president at this point so they started
they decided to start the series late in
her life you know she's not that old but
late in her professional life to the
point where she's already on the ground
running and a seasoned professional and
that was a specific choice that Shonda
Rhimes made for that series you can use
the beat sheet to structure your pilot
very specifically you can define the
post beats you can define the core
elements that make your character and
your series unique and you can plot them
out in the act structure that you're
going to use and you should have a
template show inspirational show that
you're using that uses the same
structure that you would like to use so
for example if you're using a show that
has a teaser plus five act structure on
the beat sheet it's broken down in
teaser and five acts so you will use
that as an outline template to beat out
your particular pilot it's up to you if
you feel that your series should use
this same structure in ensuing episodes
or the pilot should stand on its own as
a premise pilot as its own kind of its
own story that's not quite gonna use the
same structure these days in the
industry they like more the third
episode pilot where the pilot is written
like subsequent episodes of the series
so that's kind of thing that they like
to see more because they know what it is
they give you that question well what is
this series what are we gonna watch week
to week well you could say well the
pilot is written in the same structure
that each episode will be written in
week to week formats because you've
mapped them out
there's a male the poster yeah rain
sleet or snow